hello hello how you doing how you live
in left go and the place to be the left
go show hope you guys enjoyed child's
back Lee on Tuesday incredible dude I
hope I get to see him soon he is now our
sports uncle what a gym today we have a
treat for you a nice long conversation
with one of the best wide receivers in
the NFL Davante Adams he came through
with a bunch of his crew and we talked
about everything from Aaron Rodgers and
the first throw in which he went oh this
guy's crazy he talked about my left go
PR that's right Devante is a critic of
everyone that's putting out these
workout videos right now and it's
actually a pretty funny conversation and
he claims to be the best dunker in the
NFL and we may start a movement to find
out if he is accurate now the one thing
about this interview we recorded it and
then an hour later Randall Cobb and Clay
Matthews signed with other teams and so
that kind of stunk because I didn't
realize that was gonna happen
Randall Kyle of course went and signed
with the Cowboys which Randall Cobb is
gonna be easily the most loved cowboy
his look his demeanor he's a great guy I
actually got to spend some time with him
because of my ties with Kentucky him
going to Dallas and and being that
friend to Amari Cooper is really good
I'm curious how much he's gotten left in
terms of athletic wise but clay matthews
goes to the rams which i like that too
there's just something about those guys
i don't think they're gonna be if there
are rotational guys in that locker room
it's great to have plus now clay
matthews back in the Coliseum or he
played his USC days what a cool journey
for him to be on a Super Bowl contender
towards the end of his of his career and
getting to be in LA at USC where it all
began I think is pretty awesome but we
didn't get to talk about that stuff
so that's the one thing that I missed
from this Davante Adams interview but it
was still great and the other little
news is that Blake bortles is also on
the Rams so just announced our amendment
to favor coach to the NFL went out there
and signed bortles
and I'm gonna be honest I'm really
excited to see how this all plays out my
dream scenario is in the NFC
Championship game that something happens
I don't want Jared Goff to get hurt so
maybe he's sick and Blake bortles plays
in the NFC Championship game
if bortles can end up being like a
Fitzpatrick where he you think he's down
he just keeps coming back I would love
it
I really would I don't know how I'm
supposed to feel about bortles anymore
I'm gonna share with the homies that 33%
some truth really quick I don't really
want to hate him anymore
I can I never really hated bortles it
was always just the indictment on what
it meant to the NFL that he was a
starting quarterback but I don't really
want to lean into it anymore I'm not the
seventy guy so I don't know what I
should do so if you want to hit me up on
social ad Adam left Co or at the left
coast show Twitter and Instagram should
both have that handle now let me know
what I'm supposed to feel because I
don't know what to do he's been bortles
has been such a character for us for so
long and I'd love to know what you guys
think because I'm torn
I'm not torn about this Davante Adams
one of the best wide receivers in the
NFL he believes the best dunker here's
my interview with da 17 look at this
dude didn't meet a cup of the energy but
I had to Davante Adams da 17 you get the
logo on the neck we got the logo on the
Hat yes sir let's just start there who
came up with this it was a it was really
on a fluke so started it for to kind of
get something to go for my camp yeah
I'll do an annual camp kids camp so I
needed something to go onto t-shirts and
then had a guy make he made about maybe
30 different logos and I just went
through and picked one and I was the one
that jumped out to me 17 yes
why 17 because there's somebody uh I
don't know you ever heard of Bart Starr
of course yeah I work I work 15 in
college but the packer nation was had to
March they did what I couldn't do it
like it's retired you're like no
seriously otherwise I would probably try
but they weren't going and y17 though
next best thing I feel like the 80s
numbers don't really fit me
I'm not a war eighty that was the first
number I was given at Fresno State when
I first got there and everybody just
talking this about me I said I look like
a like old yeah it's like yeah the teens
the new things it is the new thing yeah
from the 11th to the 13th okay I could
see that yeah all right let's do there
cuz you just went to Fresno State
actually no I want to talk about New
York okay their thoughts on New York and
this jungle sure you're visiting here
where do you live in over the Cali
I'm in Cali i'ma New York Ally Cal yeah
yeah yeah I mean Cali so I mean
everybody think of Cali they think LA
right that's where everybody you gonna
go out to even go to LA but the bay is
worth it
I've seen so many efore T like lines in
your social media that I knew you're
from the bay man a law to the soil
that's another one right there - that is
good drop one on you right there yes but
what your thoughts on New York you asked
me how do I live in this stuff is
chaotic man I mean you said you thought
of my my caption was like three four
years ago is my first time coming here
and it's just like a jungle yeah yeah I
was just telling my boy Nick we were
talking about how long we've been here
it's been like three days but I feel
like here you got it it's like dog years
you got it more yes about seven so
really it's been a really long benefit
for like three weeks I try to explain
the people that people aren't rude we
just all have somewhere to go and
there's so many people that we're going
to bump into you
yeah and that's okay yeah you know me
and that's y'all culture out here it
people want to fight over that stuff I
know yeah so it's a little different
y'all fight over so I have to slow down
like if I when I go to California I need
to calm down especially because I'm like
why is why is the service taking so long
yeah yeah
you got it you got to kind of drop not
the standards but what you expect as far
as people take the time a little bit
more way of life
yeah York though I get so much done in a
week that I look up and I'm like holy
crap I had no idea I even did that yeah
I'm sure it makes you productive but
yeah I see a few Gray's popping in and
I'm losing everything bro we don't need
to pay attention I'm engaged now my life
is changing oh yes Wow and you're
married big step I am man took the step
before you man
all right what's your advice Davante
Adams marriage advice brought to you by
DEA 17 apparel buy it online at my logo
dot-com yes all right so what's your
what's your marriage advice um they're
right all the time just really give it
to him it's not worth it I've heard -
I've been married at not even a year so
it's not really I can't I can't be like
oh the first years the worst in the book
like that I don't I don't know I mean
it's been really really smooth for me
yeah I live with my wife wait we lived
together and went out since I've been in
the leagues sure I feel like that made
everything nothing really changed which
was the dopest part for me yes I feel
like everybody always says this happens
you know there's a lot less it is
there's a lot more of this yeah but you
know I got a I got a dope - so where'd
you have the wedding anywhere cool yeah
a Pebble Beach man oh it was no we're
looking at like New Jersey yeah not a
sexy there's not as sexy no but you golf
no okay well just got into golfing so
that that played it how are you I mean I
got I'm not gonna knock it out of the
park I'm bellowing consider yeah but uh
I definitely can get out there and mess
around okay I got invited to play in the
Tahoe thing this year
Oh Lake Tahoe see that's I might just go
to that just to hang out I'm the dude in
the golf cart that brings the drinks
you're the drugs that you're not allowed
to do it you don't want to scream and
get in the hole before yeah I'm proud to
be that guy okay you asked me who my
team was beforehand yeah who's a I'm an
Eagles fan
mm-hmm yeah is that because they
wondered the bow recently you know
either from blood okay well everybody
the soy every time I saw somebody same
with me I'm a warrior's fan everybody
yeah they hear I'm aware his fan oh and
then I have to deal with that so I know
that's the first time I've actually
gotten that I'm usually so obnoxious
that you could tell them from
Philadelphia yeah I mean thank you I'm
glad you could feel alright you said you
went to Fresno your connection with
Derek Carr you guys both came out the
same year he went top of the second
round you went second round as well mid
mid second around fifty third pick that
connection how many years did you guys
go to college together well let's see I
was in college for five minutes and had
to go to about five classes sustained
stay in school
yes no but we all believed it because
that's what we think about sports not
how it works there's no extra benefits I
didn't get any booster checks any of
that stuff it's all fake okay I let you
go to Alabama I think those things are
real those handshakes are hefty yeah I
didn't think they'd just be give me a
pat on the back but you and Derek two
years three years yeah no I got there
and then so I registered at my first
year hmm had some stuff with the
Clearinghouse so actually started camp
really late so they didn't really get to
assess and see if I was ready so short
I'm pissed off got to sit in the fridge
for a year first year I played with but
we were brewing we have something going
when did that start well it started the
whole time for that first the way it
goes is if you redshirt the offensive
coordinator whenever you're doing routes
on air you may not get to go because
you're not really you know playing for
that year so you know start off like
that and then it got to the point where
Derek started seeing something in me and
then you know we put that connection and
it's similar to how me and Aaron is now
right yeah I could tell the connection
is strong cuz I can also see you're a
little jealous with this a bee thing
yeah and maybe I'm guessing but I could
tell that your former guy is Derek and I
get the sense that a bee is your
favorite wide receiver he's one of them
or like a mentor to you in a way yeah
yeah yeah yeah is it weird that they're
gonna be practicing all the time this
yeah I mean I already worked out with
him and I didn't really like it he's
taking your guy it was dope but you know
I just kind of think about but but I got
my guy so yeah I just think about the
situation I got and it makes it a little
bit better oh we're gonna talk about
Rodgers in a sec hell yeah you know
about him greatest quarterback that
we've ever seen a man
one of the shelves yes yes no no I tried
to flip it with mahomes recently and the
fan base freaked out on me as they
should yeah you think that he deserves
that my thing is is I'm not talking
statistics I'm not talking I'm not
talking legacy I'm just saying ability
the greatest I've ever seen ha yeah I
need to see more I love Pat I think he
went he's one of the dopest dudes in the
league it's incredible what he can do
well I think I just had a brain fart
because Rodgers does that he invented
the things that we've never seen before
yeah whoa so why don't people would say
hey Devon say you're the best do I
receive it off the line ever mm-hmm why
don't I think you need to build that up
a little bit more there's something to
put behind it people ask me I mean it's
happening a lot lately especially ask me
about where I rank myself yeah I'm
regards to the other receivers I love
ranking wide receivers in the media you
think you're the best I'm number one
receiver in the league I would love to
hear your sales pitch and I'm not
arguing I'm listening yeah I mean it's
it's it's something that if I had to
stand up in front of that's that's the
that's the clear-cut truth of how I feel
about myself is my abilities and
obviously I'm confident and I put a lot
of work into it and it's just about
getting open man I feel like I just
don't let guys cover me I think what's
really interesting is so you just said
Aaron Rodgers the greatest in a weird
way in the media it gets held against
you yeah it's almost because I get to
hear DeAndre Hopkins go who are my
quarterbacks if I had Aaron Rodgers yeah
but you're making guys miss off the line
you're getting open you know what I mean
it's no one's ever right everyone always
has another argument to be made that's
how it goes man but I mean the beauty of
it is that there's this thing we like to
call film and when you turn the film on
if guys are next to you and you got all
solo picks then that's that's when you
can make a little bit of an argument
how many guys that you think it
mentioned in top three top five top ten
when you turn the film you go you'll say
their name I'm just curious
there's guys I mean that of course
there's there's guys that I mean you see
them
and you you question whether or not they
should get the credit that they do but
at the same time but they quote but they
put the same celebrities in the top five
every time yeah that was from you before
so there are some guys yeah I mean
that's that's that's that's how it goes
yeah you know over over time hopefully
over that changes I the NFL Pro Bowl is
the perfect example of people that
sometimes get in based off their name
yeah and you go did none of you guys
watch the film that's it man yeah I mean
it's crazy the pro Bo's is interesting
in itself yeah but yeah I definitely
agree with you I want to go back to the
a/b thing cuz I saw you had an Instagram
post for a while where there's like
April of last year he's passing a torch
to you mm-hmm
how do you see like because we want to
have these lineages of like our Mentors
where do you see your place with him and
also just in the NFL as far as it's just
like wide receiver because I think when
when you put up an image of a torch pass
yeah there's an there's an honesty was
it was just a dope and it it wasn't it
was it was the Edit it was more so I
mean I had a good game because you know
it was it was it was more of a respect
thing I'd like to edit so I'll put it up
it wasn't really too deep too much an
Instagram I think you are okay you kind
of like the the girlfriend who's like
well why don't you post me you don't
post me enough so you must not love I
experienced that yes do you get that to
even married that's the that's the best
part about the one goes away I never
dealt with it that's the best part about
it yeah I have a lot of pictures up
there it's annoying all right well then
let me look into a social media thing
that was fun and then this is not some
[ __ ] interview we're having a good
time Twitter you recently wrote and I've
never agreed with a human more I love
the people that race to stand up when
the plane lands lol I'm joking I hate
them do I now when a plane land yeah I
will sit and I will stare and I will
look around and I'm going to who is
getting up when this plane land listen I
need I'm gonna start checking boarding
passes because you better have you
better be late that plane better be like
driving you better be running to the
next terminal because it's not that
serious because it's maybe 17 seconds
quicker you're getting off the
which person is worse stand up when as
soon as it lands or clap when the plane
lands have you experienced that they
don't do that as much anymore
no I really I can't say that I've seen
it maybe in like a movie or something
but I haven't been on a plane word
follow-up question you get off your
honeymoon for some reason as soon as the
plane lands your new wife stands up
would you question out your entire
marriage we there's some things that we
got we got a restructure to do yeah
after that one I don't think we can oh
but the good thing is I put stuff like
that out there ahead of time oh you say
that before you get the fly got it I
better not be someone that stands I know
I know I don't put it that way I go
people that stand there just really like
we're on the same team those yeah I like
those people I saw their knees painted
so this she's like yeah that's stupid
this is a public service announcement
yeah for everybody in this room for
everybody listening or watching this pod
if you're one of those people Davante
Adams is looking out and he's trying to
help you I'm trying okay this is a
problem first time you see Aaron Rodgers
first time you realized he was different
was it a throw was it a play what was it
it was it was definitely a throw it was
one of the first practices we had in
OTAs I'll never forget it he stepped up
and threw it to Jarrett Boykin he was
there when I first got here when I'm one
of my boys so he stepped up ran about a
twenty yard in and Aaron had so it would
be seven on seven so just based on the
clock if you know a coverage sack or
whatever everybody's covered the
quarterback will just take off right
y'all y'all y'all got that rep so he's
getting ready to take off he steps up
flash maybe like a three yard window
I've never seen a ball come out quicker
and more on the line than that thing
it's 20 yards on the line and went
straight in between two people for a
touchdown to practice and that's when I
really said I need to start watching
what I need to watch everything that he
does because this is this man is uh not
human so you probably went to another
wide receiver like did you see that
throw and was anyone like not everybody
I mean it gets old like people don't
even tell him like we're watching film
just on any given day and I'll break
somebody off the line or whatever
they'll be like good route say when
Aaron throws the ball nobody even says
anything at this point really it's just
like like you just shake your head like
I get mad almost like I'll be sitting
there and I'll see them deuce
I just go doesn't even make sense it
doesn't make sense it's just maybe you
shouldn't you shouldn't be able to
because it's like it's almost like I
compared it to stiff Steph takes so many
shots that there's no way you practice
that you can't practice that shot like
you had one shot to make that you have
one shot to make that throw like you've
never ran here and jump and turn it
threw the ball to the left like that
you've never record cook throw in Dallas
you've never wrapped that how about were
you the one that caught the one the rise
or in Dallas no wait the one he threw it
it was like towards the end of the game
I can't remember who it is 15 20 yards
out he threw it and the ball just kept
rising and went right over a guy's ear
hole and he said so many that that game
yeah in 17 yes yes that was I mean I've
never seen a ball leave a hand and then
it's their laser beams and they're off
flicks and that was a tough thing where
and when I first got there was most
quarterbacks you can see how hard
they're about to throw but he's so
casual it looks the same it's just a
flick so sometimes I ball creep up on
you yeah and there's no joke especially
in that cold so you got to get used to
that and you with the cold to mr. Cali
yeah man have you adjusted no sleeves
for five years about to be six years I
haven't wore sleeves the point of pride
at this point at first it was something
I wasn't able to do because my whole
wideout coach was a running back and his
whole thing sleeves your phone book
right right right
and then went through a year or two
years with him and then I was like hey I
did it this long you know it's like the
dude that hasn't drank by 28 like we do
it when you see guys with sleeves does
it truly give you a mental edge oh I
don't know that they thinking about it I
don't even I'm not I'm not really locked
in on that cuz I got so much other stuff
brewing in his mind when I'm up so cold
in Appleton Wisconsin it is what was the
coldest it's been like do you remember
the degrees just recently actually he
was like the like a ridiculous ko4 I
think it was like negative with the
windchill was like negative 50 something
across the whole state of Wisconsin it
was it was terrible I think I got
negative 68 and one with the wind chill
and I think that the natural temperature
was like minus 20 do you live there also
really I don't know where you live I'm
I'm a Cali boy you think I'm chilling
out there and I wasn't sure
oh man so how does what let me answer
this is your answer this the best way I
can answer this for you so our last game
since we didn't go to playoffs yes game
was on December 30th you were a New
Year's Eve party on the 31st at home
that I was a little bit late to yes but
soon as soon as I was able to that next
day
are there any Packers that live in Green
Bay there is it is I feel bad for those
people but not a nut lice it's not about
the weather
I love Green Bay everybody knows that
yeah February you don't want to be there
whether it was right some people got
kids yeah and other things that they got
to do who are the guys that live there
do you know I don't know although my
think Mason Crosby's out there a little
bit cuz he's got like 30 kids my daniels
he spent some time I love my boy I was
looking at some of the signings that you
guys made this offseason and I'm
legitimately excited yeah so I'm gonna
lay all my cards on the table when
Rogers got hurt the guy used to do the
show with Sims now we're very excited
and the reason was is much like you see
with air and it comes so easy yeah and I
thought that the offensive philosophy
got very simple yeah I thought it was
just slant flat the whole time and Aaron
would just do amazing things and then
guess what we're in the playoffs again
you know and I thought I love one of
teams like we're seeing this with
Pittsburgh we saw this with Seattle last
year when you don't make it the team
looks around and goes where do we really
need to get better you know I'm seeing
these signings on the D line I'm seeing
like the the that kind of that changing
in the philosophies with free agents and
I feel like we're into like a new era of
Green Bay Packer do you feel the same
thing too I do I like I like where we
headed the Packers I mean they've always
been known to be more of a draft
individual mentality but but now I'm
getting some big free agent signings
that that triggers something for the
rest of the team to you see some ballers
coming in yes you know that especially
competition was I mean you come in and
you have ladarius coming here and then
you you thinking the other guys who are
below him may be like oh I got to get
right right nestled in it that just kind
of generates something that goes
throughout the whole squad to steal a
MOS from a division rival dude what is
it like what was like going up again
to give people your read on him as a
safety he's definitely one of the guys I
got a lot of respect for he's a smart
player he reminds me a lot of he's like
a mix between Micah Hyde and in haha mmm
yeah at the top of both of their games
that's a little bit of a mix I just get
except when I think about Preston Smith
and za'darius and I'm like those are
just two monsters to put on your deal is
two big dudes right yeah that's exciting
yes it is do you agree with me though
that maybe the offense did get a little
bit too simple towards the end there
yeah I mean it got it's tough to speak
on because obviously yeah you know that
but and McCarthy is a leader of men
yeah he's honest he's great to the
players he's honest he's I said it twice
he's a good guy and he's honest he's
honest yeah but but there's a reason I
think you guys went super young
up-and-coming play color mm-hmm yeah and
that's kind of the message that I
thought I saw from there yeah it's
something that a it'll be it's gonna be
a lot different too
so is we gonna we'll have a little bit
of you know there's only so many routes
sure it is not gonna be not gonna
creating the magic plays but I think a
little bit of his innovative mindset and
he's gonna you know he's had some guys
too so he's had a few guys to kind of
work out his sister tour so what do you
would it look like
have you got a taste of any of it yet
yeah I mean I've I want to met with him
so we kind of got to talk through things
but as we report in a couple weeks to be
able to really dive into it when you
hear people say that Aaron's not that
good or or he's not up and there in the
top quarterbacks the NFL or feel like
the last year there's been like some
overrated because I've heard it I've
heard that oh he was the reason like
they he's he's not free of blame and I
give him a pass on everything like I
really I think he's that special yeah
okay yeah definitely I mean you you got
a not everybody's gonna play perfect at
all time so it's easy to attack somebody
when when they make a bad throw or that
you know you drop a ball or whatever so
I mean the legacy speaks for itself is
not much needs to be said after that
when you look at other wide receivers if
because it is funny wide receivers is I
would say other than quarterbacks the
most debated who's the best and then we
make all these top five list because I
think
a Golden Age of receiver yeah like to
get like the the you the Odell's the
Julio's the Internet we got him on all
shapes and sizes like you have Mike
Evans and then with all the other stuff
like Tyree kill but like Tyree kill is
an incredible special athlete howdy how
are we supposed to compare your skill
set with someone who's so different than
you like how do how would you do it it's
tough and that's why I mean that's why
I've answered this question a few times
people ask me like about being at being
the top receiver whatever and I could
tell them like I'd say that just
strictly off of my confidence in my in
my ability that's why I tell people that
I think I'm the best receiver in the
game that's not to say that somebody
else can't be one of course that's you
know it doesn't have to be a ranking is
I think it's better to rate them you
know you rates rate receipt yeah don't
rank them because it's all do you know
who you like and then maybe maybe to do
did a charity thing now that's why you
like them more so right oh it's all
subjective yeah like when you leave here
I'm gonna say that Davante Adams is like
one of my favorite players in the NFL
because we've had this interaction and I
have more of it they're all subjective
and that's what goes into it a lot of
time absolutely he is so confident that
he knew he was gonna do this in fourth
grade you saw that I saw that so at a
fourth grade yearbook future NFL star
yeah was this the a or an MBA or NFL so
warriors or Packers of course one of the
other but how like were you thinking
about it like we're your parents talking
about it like yeah how did it how did it
slip my dad was the standout athlete I
mean he he had things going as far as
you know kids wise that kind of changed
the course of sure you know him oh how
could he I mean people think I can jump
my dad was the real jumper I mean he
still he's I mean the old man now but
he's still athletic and he still looks
good - so your dad could still dunk I
don't know if he can dunk now I mean
he's he could get up if I showed I wish
I had the picture I mean yeah but yeah
he was jumping over dudes all type of
crazy stuff he was more of a basketball
and I didn't really do football like
that until my junior year in high school
so that's why the whole MBA or sure
thing cuz I didn't know which path I was
gonna go I think I wasn't even playing
football and yet in that in that picture
so that was just just like just in case
yeah I mean you never know just in case
I try it out and what happens you in
your year well I broke my arm I played
in in Pop Warner and I was broke my left
arm I broke my left humerus three times
the same spot
damn yeah man so and so you know that
was fun at the gorillas yeah drink it
it's just God yes disguise I don't drink
it anymore can you do it no but bubble
gets anyway we're talking about junior
year junior year
football out of nowhere so my cousin
told me you should give it another try
cuz I broke my arm I was like I never
broke a bone this is stupid basketball I
don't get in yeah yeah I'm good so I'm
back to basketball and you know that's
where most of my attention was coming
from you know offers wise I've seen you
dunk yeah you get [ __ ] up yeah man
we're talking like 360 between the legs
we're talking windmills like stuff that
I used to do I wish that's why they need
to make it a celebrity dunk contest and
not the NBA dunk contest well well
though and we're gonna get back to
junior year but I
well I can't we have an NFL dunk contest
all you guys think you can ball but it's
a lot of stalkers I don't think we're
gonna show up because I mean it's a like
we talked about film yes the film is out
there so you're not gonna show up just
to show up you want to win that thing
and I'll be honest though if I see like
I've seen some D lineman like I've seen
miles Garrett yeah
at that size to do what he does pretty
impressive
it is but I mean at the end it's not a
contest we don't we yes
so you're saying right now that if every
NFL player was in a dunk contest you're
confident you'd win I unless somebody
shows me something incredible I mean
have you seen any 360 between the legs
yet well you know not that I can recall
yeah I mean that'll win NBA dunk but
I'll say this this is a possibility that
we can organize you go do the Davante
Adams NFL Duncan get it going you
brought to you by Bleacher Report and
sir out of left Co there you go I'll
emcee it do it you have a dunk contest
I've emceed
I'm like that dude that's like hot
sizzle my thing yes this is all for me
to get paid to do that yeah okay yeah
you got the voice for it too
thanks bro you go smoked a lot now
junior year
yeah what so you get out there in the
football field you go hey coach I want
to play I want to play and I played
quarterback when I played in Pop Warner
so I didn't even I'm just like I'm here
I want to look let's see what's going on
he said you can play receiver I said all
right but when ransom routes caught a
few balls and had two offers so I can I
was I'm a one star recruit they call me
a star one star they call me a to start
it but I mean to change that later it's
a one star what were your two offers San
Diego State Fresno State and see you
played a year and a half of football two
years of football yep and who was the
coach that recruited you like what did
he see Keith Williams it was I mean he
just he saw a raw leaper leaper who
would just the the measurable so he said
hey I'm gonna try to take this kid teach
him some stuff about white out play cuz
he's I mean he's the white out guru out
there so you know Pat he'll I'll be sure
from Fresno State so I got to be under
them for a year didn't even get the play
that year but then played to and he felt
I was ready for the big show Wow yeah
happening quick lightning fast man
everything is I see a lot of your posts
too like you still have a solid chip on
your shoulder - yeah weird
where were the most doubters where as in
what you mean by what stage your life
did you feel the most 2015 when I had my
mod in my down year my sophomore year
was sophomore in the league year was was
definitely when they they try to get
after me a little bit but uh I mean I
feel like there was even an article that
was like maybe they should release
Davante Adams maybe that was everywhere
really it was cut it was Janis over
Adams Jeff Dennis my worst mo teammates
love Jeff shout out to Jeff but yeah
they everybody they they did not they
couldn't really they thought the first
year was a league they thought it was a
for the first year I kind of came on the
scene I didn't burst on the scene or
crazy how some of the other ones right I
think that that's honestly what's
playing into your lack of respect now
well I'm saying the lack of respect just
based on they saw the the down year in
15 and ago there's no way he's actually
that much better now
what he was then so people just can't
really put their head around it and then
they don't watch the details either so
so obviously the people that consume our
podcast in the show and all that they're
big time fans I'm a fan of my core and
we'll never experience what it's like to
get to see all these things and have no
control over and there were you clipping
articles you like reading them you
saving them I don't are you just in the
gym going I'm gonna kill so I deleted my
I mean it wasn't even that intense
because I felt in my heart that the
Packers knew what the deal was they knew
the jate they knew I was injured I was
banged up which is I mean I don't wanna
use any of that as an excuse I wouldn't
do that and it's so far removed anyway
that no matter none of it matters anyway
yeah but but yeah I just I really just
said hey as long as I'm around I just
need to be healthy and I'll be able to
make it happen I tell the story like I
haven't told this part but like I fueled
my own career through haters for a long
time yeah like I was my first job I'm in
the middle of Nebraska Hastings Nebraska
I was a news reporter making eighteen
thousand dollars a year and all my boys
were in New York and all my boys were
brunch and on weekends and all my boys
were taking pictures well back when
Facebook was popping good and I'm
sitting there being like y'all I'm a
grind [ __ ] hard when I get to New
York we gonna see who's got the table
yeah
and hate burns hard it like it fuels you
like it's great to get up at 6:00 in the
morning with a little bit of hate it's
nothing like you but eventually you got
to change your fuel and you got to burn
clean yeah and that's when it's like my
discipline and all that stuff yeah but I
don't think it's bad to have haters you
got it you got a head I mean if you know
if you're not getting hated on I think
that uh you're not doing something right
you got you got to be getting hated on
cuz in I mean or you're not doing it big
enough yes
one of the other because I mean they
don't care to hey do you need more
haters I'll round up please follow me on
Twitter if you want that's fine uh
speaking of Twitter what other tweets do
I have hear from you
you saw mahomes banned from basketball
and I love this yeah you're the quote
the number II of your reached has a
voice mailbox that's not been set up yet
yeah I mean can they even come to you
and
don't play basketball I mean I'm sure
that I don't know I don't want to get
you in [ __ ] trouble right no they
they're not coming to me I mean I I who
yeah I mean that's and that's not a
secret but I mean you want to be safe
with all the Nets though right
but I see Derwin James Duncan like it's
it's part of your guys offseason routine
and I think it's also part of your
identity and yeah I mean I'm a Hooper
that's that was my I played football
because I felt like it was the best
thing to do for me in my life but
basketball was my first love I love
football that's that's obviously I
wouldn't be playing it yeah of course if
I didn't have a special special love for
it but it started with basketball so you
know as soon as I get in office it's
offseason before I'm even actually
working back working out yeah the ball
was I'm in there getting shots up at
least who would be drafted to the
Davante Adams NFL starting five mm-hmm
you're going at what position one or two
I'll probably I'll probably go to okay
shooting guard yeah
who's your point who's your NFL point
guard ooh you put me on a spot right
like that I mean I can ask you to come
back earlier and I could have thought
about it but not now I'm gonna sit here
and just have an awkward silence while I
think about it it's awkward silence is
brought to you by Davante Adams 17
merchandise get him up on Twitter be a
hater and sign up now I'll give you mine
so I'll put myself at the two on point
I'm gonna put tarik Cohen at the point
okay I was gonna say Tyree he'll have
you seen him who I have not he can
probably fly he can hoop I know it threw
me off because usually the fast ones are
the ones as out of control if you don't
handle he could shoot a little bit I saw
me yeah they did I once they did his own
little a celebrity little basketball
game or what have some dudes that I've
seen you think guys like that could
upset when you say little basketball
game because their whole lives are
talked about how small they are
I hope not because that's just
insecurities yeah at that point all
right so my point guards to Rico and
you're going Tyree kill three four five
I'm gonna go Kaleo Campbell as my five
great size it's often okie also would
he'd call out a screen he likes Cruz
like oh there's definitely a screen
behind me I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
Julius paper even though he does
just retired tired yeah I'm gonna go
Julia's peppers because he's the hoop
with us in Green Bay so I got to see
what he's about I'm gonna go I stretch
for as I'm gonna go Al Shean Jeffrey I
feel like he's got a little bit of sighs
I probably should have gone somebody
more athletic but I'm an Eagles fan
oh that's why that's why that's this I
mean just based off the the height alone
that's not been outside range I'm taking
Aaron Rodgers I don't even know if he
can hoop but I just want him on me like
there's a three that says that's his big
thing his mid-range he thinks he's
really good mid-range guy you haven't
seen that his Twitter it's like his hash
to eat hashtags like mid-range on the
most random stuff that so he's like a 45
year old guy at the Y that's basically
that's exactly what it is exactly so
he's probably a great screen and roll
with like a no-look pass to you and then
he wants credit for you dunking that's
exactly what it is he'll get the hoops
going for sure mahomes can ball too
apparently apparently cannot call I'm
kind of mad that I didn't even think of
that yeah that was that was kind of
still have a spot up and so just put him
there I put him he can he can go to the
three okay um you know I got I got to
put Jimmy somewhere no no no excuse me
back up back up back up let's back up
let's back up my three is Richard
Rodgers really nobody understands this
and I can't wait so he see this rich is
probably I mean obviously behind me next
best Hooper in the league Richard
Rodgers number 82 tighten it for the
Packers recently for the Eagles catcher
of two Hail Marys who Hail Marys is the
second-best NBA's NFL player basketball
behind you no question get out of here
like a refrigerator and he and he shoots
like Ray Allen and he what that may mean
we have competitive one-on-one games we
got that yeah we do the NBA 101 where
you only get two dribbles yes so oh yeah
you can hoop wow yeah I know that yeah
speaking though there's all these videos
on the internet this offseason
guys playing basketball and then we
talked about how athletic they are yeah
I was joking around last year and I
called it left go PR that any player
coming back from rehab or any player
that needed to get better put videos of
them working out on the internet the
week after I said this O'Dell started to
do it I have learned
that I may have influenced that camp you
did I'm very confident okay okay you
recently commented I see all your
workout videos we're gonna see it's a
phenomenon right now in the NFL it is it
is every player has a highlight tape
they're doing the latter with a Drake
song in the background and it's one
minute and then the entire fanbase goes
oh [ __ ] he's gone Gibson's grinding dude
what it's we're not the only one that
see it look man we just got to start
just just just jotting this down like
keep a diary just everybody you see just
so you can keep a close eye on them
during the season and see how all of
that all those videos when they have in
the park and they go - back to the hood
and go do whatever to be cute yeah I
love it I just want to see because I
don't see much of that being able to
have benefit as far as covering people
you're getting motivated right now I'm
just trying to get you up to speed
that's okay so you're telling me it's
kind of a ruse that's exactly what I'm
saying
mmm was there any single video that you
actually went oh that's actually a good
one
yeah no I've seen I've seen videos but
like I have you know times where I want
to post just to kind of show people do
it it's more it's more further for for
you know educational purposes I want to
show the kids you know stuff like run
drop running stuff like that where I
used to do a thing where maybe it was
maybe for like a couple weeks where I
will post like a clip from the game and
break it down why you know whatever work
and kind of just get to get to the nitty
gritty like that but um now it's just
just a show just to make everybody think
you're grinding when you just not really
not really going that hard like that
alright so left go PR for you because I
want you to own the title of best dunker
in the NFL I think you ever see like
those guys like TJ s and stuff like that
where they like they do like a
basketball trick and they talk to the
camera you did like a 360 between the
legs and then called out another NFL
player like I think I'm the great like
Odell I don't think you could do this
yeah I just don't think the obese no no
no see as you can tell I like to create
Kayano I don't know we in New York
like that look I just how much that
shocky nothing happened I was blown away
blown away
yes that was probably the most shocking
thing that could have happened it's
offseason and which wild is is in an
offseason where Le'Veon goes to the Jets
the Antonio Brown rocks a gold mustache
and gets his way to the Raiders O'Dell
being traded is still probably the most
shocking and Judas said all that other
stuff I would have said there's no way
no way I can top that no way yeah we've
heard so much about like NBA culture and
how NBA players talk to each other when
something like that happens does it send
shockwaves for the NFL like oh my god
who's talking to who how does that work
no everybody I mean as buzz as soon as
it pops up on people whose phones I mean
and obviously I want to reach out to
certain people but in that situation I'm
like man I can only imagine the type of
everybody's talking to that fool I mean
he probably getting a new number after
this whole experience so I mean it's
dope I mean it's gonna be good because
you know they got something going over
there and Cleveland's right now so I'm
all in on I don't want to see it's gonna
be interesting it's now as a fan of the
Eagles we had the dream team experience
we know that when the when the Warriors
first came together it takes some time
the same thing with the heat but there's
something about the Baker Odell
Jarvis dynamic that feels clean yeah it
doesn't it makes too much sense Jarvis
and Odell fit perfectly together yeah
Baker is the guy where when the
Cleveland media and Cleveland don't ruin
this like when y'all start getting all
O'Dell because he like there's video of
him jogging one time Baker's gonna be
the guy that gets up on the podium and
says come at me yeah like he's like he
will do that I'll respect it feels clean
yeah this is there's definitely they got
a good thing going over there right now
I know it almost felt like he was the
quarterback before you know like he's
been there for five years yeah yeah yeah
and it's gonna be good and he's got all
the confidence in the world right now
too and we know those other two do so
he's gonna be fine
all right here's like an in the Green
Bay Packers weeds like Green Bay Packers
fans want so much Aaron Jones yes as
they should
what's the deal with the real deal and I
called it I call this
when he first got there when he still
had a little gut on him I said this guy
could tell about how you move I said he
that's my dark horse right there
he was [ __ ] but it's like a different
style of running like he doesn't he
plays he plays football full-speed mmm
no like people can't tackle them because
they ready for him to break down and
start shaking when he's just swerving he
cuts off his inside foot which is the
weirdest thing I've ever seen
he literally begins with the left foot
here so by the time that right foot hits
usually you see chopped up chop and then
people can break down and what I just
running right by you
everything just walk he's a swerve
everything he doesn't shake people he
just runs away from there but I mean the
Seattle game alone last year yeah he did
everything everything man he's talented
we got we got some good backs I think
look you you guys are one of my I don't
even think you're a sleeper team because
I think when your quarterback has Aaron
Rodgers and we have talent like you on
the field and the free agents but I look
at your team and the additions you made
I think Detroit has made a lot of good
moves just in your division we know
where Chicago is and see North I mean
with the Vikings - it's a pretty awesome
division to be in it is it is it's
really competitive right now I know it's
kind of been all over the place within
the past couple years but once we get
our thing going back right we'll be back
on top in the North quote tweet women
lie men lie but numbers don't and you
added derrick karr hashtag underrated
hashtag steals was this right around the
draft yep you guys do you guys think
you're both gonna go first round I knew
I didn't go to New York because I felt
like I didn't want to be the guy to sit
in that [ __ ] green that would have
been the worst possible thing so I said
I'm not gonna do that I knew there was a
possibility so we had the ESPN cameras
at the house right which was bad enough
and not going first round and having
everybody have to leave and so then we
up we all were black the next day and it
was a funeral for the rest of the squaws
out there that didn't take me that's
such a good lie oh my god and then fast
forward about a year my QB is better
than yours whahahahahahaha was when he
won MVP yeah man yeah it's uh it's one
of those things where a of course
go first round but to end up playing
with arguably one of the greatest
quarterbacks of all time it's a blessing
then you cannot complain I mean it's a
little cold but I'll deal with that if I
can if I can be out there with a future
yellow jacket this is my last jokey one
are you actually a big Jackie Chan fen
or is that just a picture at the wax
museum please I wasn't sure if I was
like if you have like a super secret
huge wish though that would that would
be more interested in the wax museum
picture but not I was sad to say that
favorite movie of all time
Friday mmm or you know what Friday your
Friday is the easy route I must say
prisoners I don't even know what that is
you don't know what prisoners is no no
Jake Gyllenhaal's yes yes that's
probably my he's in my top three top
three actors yes and he I mean because
the versatility is unreal but great
movie if you ever seen that I want to
make a bleached robots Davante Adams top
three actors who were the other two I'm
going another easy brown state news oh
but just gotta love Denzel man that's
every Denzel role yeah he smacks a table
and I'm like looks around that's it you
got it
my favorite movie is Ace Ventura 2 and
nature calls the one with the slinky and
he's in the jungle you're gonna be I
know exactly what movie you're talking
about but I've never seen it it comes at
make it out of the Rhino that's your
part wide open favorite musician man
that [ __ ] has changed a lot isn't it
yeah how Kali you're gonna go on me I'm
not even gonna go Cathy I'm not I'm
gonna do that right now I'm gonna go I
mean I gotta say just just out of
loyalty Meek Mill um let me in
Philadelphia appreciate ya dreams and
nightmares can you do the entire dreams
and nightmares open or are you with a
guy in the club that like you're like
I've been like you kind of turned down
really quick look that's what I did you
know anything about me you know is
there's not many songs I don't know the
words to really a place I listen to so
much music anything that I'm interested
in I'm most likely gonna learn the words
by a week I'm a big Anderson PAC guy
I feel like he's from like the Stockton
area who Anderson PAC paa Kay who's on
the road and then you don't listen to
enough music I was I got it he just did
an album with dr. Dre he's like a
hip-hop soul [ __ ] guy okay I'll play
them for you afterwards yeah yeah yeah I
got hear this and then and then I'm
going down all like the music routes but
we'll bring it back to football what
what am I expecting this year men like
what what what are you writing down a
lot what's the the stuff that you're
saying to yourself about this upcoming
season I don't I don't necessarily like
setting no not goals I mean more like
mantras like what are you like where the
words you're saying to yourself keep
going that's as much as always been my
philosophy you keep going because I feel
like I never got to like even in college
if I were to play at another year in
college like that that's 1724 tell ya
would I feel like I could have shattered
that so as long as I'm in it I feel like
I just got to keep elevating me because
I've never never never settled on you
know I'm never content with where I'm at
so they've got to keep pushing Packers
fans are gonna [ __ ] love this
appreciate you thank you for coming in
oh you know man
and I'm gonna say right now that we're
gonna give you the crown of best dunker
in the NFL I think we should start well
I think this would be a physical crown
for this deal but what I think I'd like
to do is have other people like
challenge you and we do like I really
think launching a dunk contest is a
smart but I think so too and then that
was the just based off of who who just
show up there you go Mike I just want to
show I just want to be with my head my
PGN asses on sitting there just waiting
ball under my arm waiting and nobody
sorry so I know you have a video clip as
before about you doing a dunk if you
make a new one even if you just post it
to your page or we'll link up yeah I'm
gonna post it on our show account but
I'm gonna get some bleacher report likes
under it I'm you separate them I'll get
some of this and then we'll just we'll
start the competition now we're gonna do
it man be a seventeen once again check
out the merchandise download that follow
him on twitter at teh 15 adam why is
that 15
I made it in college gotcha that's where
star add mistakes my college number
won't change okay Davante Adams